my kids are on the couch lazing about I
practice this now I know how bad you
want to talk about you doing it I'm
ignoring it and I don't want to talk
about I'm just saying what I do is I
keep my elbow to the ground like that
when I get a get no fives for you know
no fire traffic for you um
no very very little I don't know how I'm
gonna get home can I stay with you Brian
yeah you could say whether you want to
roll I'm just gonna keep ignoring your
jujitsu I'm a Higgin I'm a Hagen Machado
student now I had a private with Hagen
Machado and my rear naked in my
guillotine sick how was the ER pilot
let's knock this out how was your
private what why did you do a private he
gave Machado's a friend of mine where's
my favorite comedian and he'll tell you
that okay I miss favorite comedian okay
it's my pleasure my friends never sees
Matt in your shows brother he's been in
my shows a couple times nope never seen
him Michael Bisping came to my show
front row row but like you know the
first boot live in Orange County he does
Michael Bisping paying for tickets to
come see me with his wife and my buddy
kmac was came up and he comes up me
because Michael Bisbing zin the [ __ ]
line I go what he goes he's coming back
I go we'll bring him in his another pay
for [ __ ] tickets it was great he's he
had a knee replacement ya know and he
has one fake I fake knee yeah he's his
body's been throw it there won't be a
fighter huh yeah you want to be a flight
accessible one oh yeah yeah did you see
how did you talk to him after anything
yeah yeah great he loved it he [ __ ]
loves comedy he's he's the loudest
laugher and 500 people on the loud dude
guys clapping he loved it man he [ __ ]
loved it but he um he looks great he
like he actually looks great he's
probably 225 by the way photo one one Oh
everybody's like everybody in the room
is like this they were like dude he's a
[ __ ] house he's like I I got almost
you where I knows I'm fat like oh you're
not fat dude you're just muscular look
at all look at that is so bad
look at that dude I am it was like two
times the size of his other leg to you
right oh oh yeah man oh yeah
just a lifetime of training so this is
an entire Laker just did he always have
bad knees did you know Wow yeah man I
think his eye looks way better though it
doesn't look black like it used to cuz
the oil
it was detached and there was oil in the
eye now whatever he did he fixed it I
think and so it looks you know it's
different but it doesn't look bad at all
what's a it's a fake guy he's a fake I
take that yeah I didn't know that so
he's blind
I didn't know that so he lost his eye
because he was able to see I didn't know
that that sucks
that sucks yeah yeah so he's blind in
one [ __ ] eye have you seen anyone
takes it up no he's got a new [ __ ]
what just zero by the way I wore my
glasses my dark glasses as I said to
hide from the Commission I mean get a
load of this check this out look at this
baby boys whoo
know what I'm saying that's why I used
to wear [ __ ] sunglasses baby boy
and he puts it back in so wait this was
a fake eyes friends all his eyes
actually looking a lot better he's had
some work I'm an idiot
dammit I'm not in on it I don't know
yeah man I'm friends it it's [ __ ] my
old biz being and I trained with Higa
Machado it's like I'm right am I the
toughest actually you know I think so
dude am I the toughest after you know I
I will say I said he can said he said
I'm gonna make you a lean mean fighting
machine I said I just want to all I want
from you is I want you to teach me to
give I want to get to a point where I'm
given sob fits and he just started belly
laughing really yeah because of course
it'll never happen is that Cooper it
looks like it training with Bradley
Bradley and Brian look at us both couple
cuties only Bradley's much
better-looking than me God you ain't
like [ __ ] I look like a pig in here dude
no I mean he's got he's a movie star
movie star TV guy movie star TV guy
movie star a regular guy that's how I
use the hands of Phil who else does he
get oh oh [ __ ] Syrian blues Aryan
yeah he can teaches everybody but he's a
lot of stars yeah he's such a [ __ ] it
what his [ __ ] schools in Beverly
Hills it's right there in Beverly Hills
you know it's great as with Randy
Couture Jesus Christ is with some hot
chick he's a killer
but I loved life so love the way
teachers witch named Jonah hell
Jonah Hill he's up there with Jonah Hill
- yeah he's a [ __ ] great guy he's
funny and he's you know but I at least
you know he's as good as a castle there
is with Ashton Kutcher he's as good as
it gets
Ashley's looking a little thick trainer
to the stars man trainer with the Stars
um you know what I felt special I'm the
least famous guy he says Wow I [ __ ]
didn't go to an Ivy you think you tell
Bradley Cooper's his favorite actor
meantime he genstat
and I Joe this hill shoes man he's his
favorite my favorite comic he I've heard
that from gorilla gorilla those I gotta
Ben he ghen your show cuz he fathers
knew all my jokes yep [ __ ] you none of
our comics man don't piss on my parade
oh there is with I'll bring he get up
there right now there's girl at your
head say yeah yeah dude but I'm the
comic I'm not a [ __ ] actor and don't
take this away from me he loves my I'm
his favorite comic yeah he said it
yeah no dough no other lives with
[ __ ] yeah so not famous no this is
[ __ ] dude he's a badass though man
yeah he's a killer
he's just a great teacher little details
and that's what you need did you need
the little details I'm I'm gonna start
those blanking might get crazy with
training oh there's Frank no I might get
crazy with Julian Franco hey miss I miss
you [ __ ] sir I might get crazy with it
for real did it one of his black belts
that was there dude Vin Diesel [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah that's Bendis like every accident
every actor including me every [ __ ]
actor wants to be tough look at how sad
we are Mel Gibson dude with Mel Gibson
guess you know some people I do that
I'll need you and your get it off Oh
[ __ ] right nah nah oh you thought oh
you thought you're special
oh wow wow
no it seems like he trains every
celebrity in the world I am special or
ginger his favorite and you don't say
that to anybody else
hey I'm very calming don't need though
there's an eagle
yeah that was guys who's in Kazakh Stan
what was he doing there
he just does seminars all over the world
in four yeah it's not a bad life no hell
no not a bad life he's such as Machado's
are great people hey Jon shock is
amazing judo Jonah track I'm not
familiar such I don't know that my
personal basis such good I've met a few
of them but they've always been super
nice they're all good I've never trained
with any of them
yeah they're all just great just great
well he he is the biggest of them all
he's just the [ __ ] house everything
he thought he added 355 fights shih tzu
matches without losing month don't say
fights though it'd be just a mattress
yeah especially around real fighters
yeah yeah it's a sport
oh yeah it's a beautiful thing yeah
beautiful Jonah Hill he's uh there's my
boy is he back here now two magno used
to train with him all the time love him
is he back there being skinny again
what's he doing he turn down the role of
the penguin he did why then I can
understand that
why wouldn't they ask you to be the
Riddler you know I'm saying I'd love to
Billy I'd love to if I might acting um
you'd be the Riddler and a [ __ ] heart
be as I would see I like I like I don't
like out of shape you know I like jerk
Joanie like think I like skinny Jonah
yeah he's a very nice fella I think
Jonah Hill is a hell of an actor he's
phenom I think he's all good yeah I
think he's as good as it gets I really
do it ready for this yeah
he will tell you nuts all right listen
to me listen to me all [ __ ] aside
take it back now take it back I think
you'd be Jonah Hill
take it back just take it back nope on
his he could train for 10 years and I'm
not joking now well he's blue belt
shot the [ __ ] out under Machado shut up
and enjoy the hangars Trenton I like him
very much I was younger now easy I'm a
younger man I love that guy younger I
love that guy younger I love Jonah hell
there isn't a sport including jiu-jitsu
I don't care how long don't I'm feeling
rest Lee you know I'm feeling wrestling
cuz I'm training now I told you I
already said this to you on text now he
can pay his own shitty your nights you
next private that bump Danny DeVito's in
there I hate to be stopped raining on my
parade dude I trained now I don't just
box but I roll
now it's gonna sting a little bit what
we can't get you in 2020 Denzel I could
text him right now Watson's book he can
write now nope he and I roll
he loves my stand-up then give a [ __ ]
about me to say that your fingers dude
stop it he comes to my shows Michael
Bisping and he gonna try I don't want
any of this it's all good dude
tie me in knots don't say any in what
about you and Bradley Cooper though I
bet Bradley I love brother
oh dear I'm beating my beat I don't
think so really big hit but you know
I've asked Bradley he'll tell you he
doesn't want even why is he doesn't it's
okay he's a Philly kid now I know do at
least ring you're scrappy you know this
you're scrappy yeah yeah don't don't be
when it comes down to it I'll tell you
what when people are watching go hey
Brian
let's you can be them do the most
pull-ups hey Brian let's see him in
those push-ups you know I mean that
competition of appeal watching and then
I go 52 year old Brian becomes 30 year
old Brian he beats everybody you know
this oh you talking about I'm talking
about every look well no you beat
everyone when you talk about your
openers on the road
no I open doesn't rotor better than
Moloch is did you beat them Marcus kill
Moloch no he looks in shape he's a he's
been boxing since he was seven ya know
they're saying you beat him
no no Moloch no he's good enough when we
boxed to just he just stands right in
front of me
he was old a nice you know I mean come
on well the [ __ ] it's a holding this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]